i
totally lost it backstage it's hard to
put into words and one of the industry's
biggest comeback stories the country
music trio who today just go by the
chicks went 5-5 at the 2007 grammy
awards a few years earlier they were one
of the most popular female groups in
music history
[Music]
a legion of fans sold out concerts a
number one single on the country charts
and then came those infamous 12 words
just days before the u.s invaded iraq in
2003 the chicks were performing a
concert in london when lead singer
natalie mains said this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
many felt the criticism of the president
was un-american and their once loyal
country radio fans were outraged one
specific death threat on natalie
at a time had a place had a weapon i
mean everything you will be shot dead
stations stopped playing their music
album sales dropped and ticket sales
plummeted we are raised our whole lives
to be so proud of free speech and this
is our
claim and this is what we are fast
forward 2006 the international uproar
was chronicled in the documentary shut
up and sing we're going to voice them
for their music and we're going to
boycott you for playing it if you don't
stop playing it the chicks also
addressed the controversy with a new
album taking the long way and another
chart-topping single not ready to make
nice
[Music]
we didn't write a song thinking oh we'll
really show them let's do one that they
really can't play
their newfound success appeared to
indicate a cultural shift leaving their
scandal in the rearview mirror the dixie
chicks are back betting their careers on
a whole new style is america ready i'd
have to say yes i think about it i'd
have to say yes
of course their true welcome back was at
the grammys where they took home
trophies for album of the year best
country album record of the year song of
the year and best country performance by
a duo or group were you
surprised completely spread
yeah truly truly
all the last years we were faking but
this year
on show night there was one question on
everyone's minds
does it sort of feel like vindication
everyone asked that i know it is it's
the b word tonight
give me a week to think about it i don't
know i think grammy's is always about
the music in some people's minds i think
there might have been something of a you
know a cheering section for us because
what we've gone through but you know i
do feel like this is the strongest album
we've ever made
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we never
left we never made a conscious
decision to leave country music we just
have to play music that moves us i think
we've learned over the last three years
that you know not to expect anything and
uh so and it's sweeter that way you know
to be truly surprised we were
[Music]
you